[Música]
hola qué tal la plática que les voy a
dar ahora es una plática que nos va a
llevar muy al futuro prácticamente les
voy a hablar de ciencia ficción pues
vamos a ver cómo se puede hacer para
colonizar un planeta básicamente a mí
siempre me ha gustado la ciencia ficción
desde que soy pequeño recuerdo que leía
novelas de frank herbert de hard tours y
clark de isaac asimov y siempre me
cautivó mucho la idea de ver el futuro
de ver hacia donde nos podía llevar la
tecnología la ciencia lo que creamos los
seres humanos en particular la ciencia
ficción que a mí me gusta es la ciencia
ficción espacial porque combina mis
pasiones o sea naves espaciales robots
el espacio la astrofísica este tipo de
historias cuentan una visión de
exploración porque ya aquí en la tierra
prácticamente conocemos todos los
rincones el siguiente lugar que vamos a
llamar fronteras es el espacio y aunque
llevamos alrededor de medio siglo
explorando el espacio realmente es un
lugar bastante nuevo muy desconocido
hace 120 años una de las novelas que más
me ha gustado de las que conozco desde
que estoy pequeño que me cautivó es la
guerra de los mundos
ha habido innumerables adaptaciones de
esta historia desde historias en
películas en cómics videojuegos adaptan
también elementos de esta historia pero
en particular algo que a mí siempre me
ha gustado es que el autor hg wells
era maestro de biología era un
científico sabía de ciencia en
particular cuando crecía aunque sea
estudiar ciencias me llamó mucho la
atención el poder que tiene la ciencia
ficción y en particular las novelas
escritas por personas que hacen ciencia
para ver el futuro y para divulgar la
ciencia se incluyen en la novela
elementos sobre evolución sobre
adaptación sobre viajes en el espacio
etcétera la historia para no darles
spoilers de la trata acerca de una
invasión de marcianos a la tierra
vienen llegan aquí y se enfrentan con el
ejército más fuerte de la época que era
el ejército británico hace 120 años hoy
en día las historias que contamos en la
ciencia ficción son un poco diferentes
tratamos ahora ha sido integrar aspectos
multidisciplinarios dentro de las
historias usamos la astronomía usamos
ingeniería usamos física biología
química sociología psicología usamos una
gran cantidad de elementos de ciencia de
lo que sabemos ahora para contar
historias de lo que ocurre allá arriba
muchas de las historias utilizan
elementos muy interesantes de lo que se
están aprendiendo las ciencias pero
también y esto se los digo desde el
punto de vista de alguien que estuvo en
la academia la ciencia utilizado los
científicos utilizamos también elementos
que conocemos de la literatura para
incorporarlos a nuestra labor a mí me
encanta leer alguna novela que presenta
alguna idea extraña novedosa y digo o
esto estaría interesante explorar lo que
pasa si el hecho números que pasa si se
aplicó mis conocimientos a esta idea a
ver qué es lo que sucede y es lo que se
está haciendo
recientemente algunas historias que
estoy consumiendo integran equipos de
científicos a la producción de películas
a la producción de series a la
producción de videojuegos para poder
integrar estos elementos y algunas de
estas historias hablan sobre la
colonización de marte que es lo que
estamos viendo aquí es una escenario de
una historia de una serie de ciencia
ficción donde presenta un escenario de
terraformación marciana los pasos que se
siguen para llegar a este momento en la
historia del universo que se nos está
narrando no son especificados no hay
claridad como lo hicieron para llegar
ahí pero utilizando ciencia y utilizando
lo que sabemos de la tecnología ahorita
podemos hacer un mapeo de cómo podemos
llegar a ese momento
actualmente existen proyectos para que
dentro de 5 años aproximadamente
tengamos naves espaciales que permitan
llevar a seres humanos a marte dentro de
cinco años
estas naves propuestas por hace un año
aproximadamente por la compañía spacex
nos permitirían llegar no sólo a marte
sino a la luna o viajar alrededor del
mundo estas son cosas que ya se están
desarrollando que se están aplicando en
la ciencia ficción uno de los grandes
problemas siempre es el asunto de cómo
nos trasladamos de un punto a otro tener
naves espaciales que nos permitan llegar
a marte no significa que va a ser fácil
llegar a marte las distancias son tan
tan tan grandes tan grandes que es algo
que a mí me volvió muy humilde cuando
tome conciencia de cuán grande es el
universo para resolver esto las las
historias de la ficción siempre
presentan algún aparato alguna
tecnología que permite viajar incluso
más rápido que la luz y llegar a estos
lugares en cuestión de días horas
minutos en el caso de la tecnología con
la que contamos y en el caso de la
ciencia de lo que conocemos actualmente
no tenemos esta tecnología entonces
necesitamos encontrar formas eficientes
de viajar a los otros planetas
si quisiéramos llegar a marte por
ejemplo ocurre algo extraño bueno no es
extraño si uno sabe cómo se mueven allá
arriba las cosas
marte y la tierra están girando
alrededor del sol resulta ser que las
velocidades a las que están dando
vueltas alrededor del sol no son iguales
entonces va a haber momentos donde la
tierra y marte van a estar juntos o muy
cercanos y momentos donde van a estar
del otro lado del sol a una distancia
muy muy grande
las distancias son tan inmensas que los
números que utilizamos para describir
las a estas alturas escapan nuestra
nuestra imaginación cuando marte está
cerca de la tierra está a 55 millones de
kilómetros en el caso más lejano cuando
está del otro lado del sol lo vemos a
400 millones de kilómetros ustedes dirán
bueno no es tanto es ok claro que ha
sido mucho para que se imaginen esto
vamos a vamos a hacer un ejercicio aquí
los astrónomos tenemos esta costumbre de
utilizar una unidad de medida
popularizada por la ciencia ficción que
es en la medida del año luz el año luz
lo que explica es la distancia que
recorre un rayo de luz en el transcurso
de un año podemos decir que esta unidad
de medida es el tiempo luz en el caso
del sistema solar las distancias son muy
pequeñas
no necesitamos utilizar el año luz para
poder expresar estas distancias lo que
utilizamos son minutos luz
el tiempo que tarda la luz a llegar a la
luna
el objeto celeste más cercano de la
tierra es de un segundo luz un segundo
el tiempo que a mí me tarda dar un paso
la luz acaba de llegar a la luna
en el caso de marte cuando tenemos al
planeta rojo más cercano a la tierra la
distancia se recorre por la luz en tres
minutos esa es la distancia que nos
separa entonces esto es un problema
porque si la luz tarda tres minutos en
llegar a marte nosotros los seres
humanos vamos a tardar meses alrededor
de seis meses en llegar a marte
aproximadamente esto lo saben las
compañías que están proponiendo
exploración en marte nada lo sabe space
ex lo sabe y debido a eso se pone
atención a un evento que se le llama la
oposición de marte cuando marte y la
tierra se encuentran muy muy cerca es a
lo que se le llama la oposición este
escenario se le conoce también como la
ventana de lanzamiento porque podemos
mandar naves espaciales para allá en en
estos momentos cuando están cerca los
planetas pero en el caso de marte ocurre
cada dos años y dos meses entonces
curiosamente el dato con el evento que
ocurrió hace un mes aproximadamente el 6
de febrero de este año del 2018
space se expuso un auto a darle vueltas
al sol
proyecto era una prueba para hacer para
probar el cohete más grande que se
encuentra en estos momentos en
funcionamiento en la tierra que es el
falcon heavy este cohete permite mandar
objetos en este caso un auto que fue una
prueba a la órbita marciana y se
aprovechó porque este año 2018 tenemos a
marte muy muy cerca
en marte
es el único planeta que sabemos los
seres humanos que está habitado por
robots este de aquí es un robot hito que
se llama curiosidad curiosity en inglés
y es un robot hito que nos está mandando
mucha información muy interesante acerca
de cuál es la situación en marte marte
para por ejemplo para que nos demos una
idea de qué es lo que está pasando allá
su atmósfera consiste alrededor del 95%
del dióxido de carbono es un gas que
tenemos aquí en la tierra que es un gas
de efecto invernadero y es el gas que
consumen las plantas para sobrevivir que
después lo transforman en oxígeno
podríamos decir bueno si montamos un
montón de plantas en este cohete lo
mandamos a marte las plantamos de alguna
manera y van a empezar a producir
oxígeno podríamos hacerlo el problema es
que la atmósfera marciana es 100 veces
más tenue que la atmósfera de la tierra
si quisiéramos ir a vivir a marte si
quisiéramos tener plantas allá
necesitamos aumentar la densidad y la
presión de la atmósfera
esto es importante porque necesitamos
una presión más alta para mantener el
agua en estado líquido en la superficie
si la presión es muy baja el agua muy
automáticamente se disipa es algo que os
ocurre en espacio ocurre en el vacío y
en marte ocurre no podríamos respirar
ahí porque la densidad es muy baja
sabemos que en el pasado la pus fuera
marciana fue más densa nathan los
observo obsequiado imágenes donde
podemos ver cauces de ríos muy viejos
que ahora están secos que nos indican
esta evidencia entonces si quisiéramos
llegar a marte lo que necesitamos hacer
es transformar la atmósfera de marte la
atmósfera de marte para transformarla
necesitamos hacer algo necesitamos ya
sea llevar tanques de aire para allá lo
cual es imposible no es conveniente pero
podemos modificarlo utilizando elementos
que ya se encuentran en marte
afortunadamente en los polos de marte
con tenemos agua congelada agua y
dióxido de carbono congelado si podemos
aumentar la temperatura del planeta
podríamos derretir todo este material
hacer que entre a la atmósfera hacer que
haya charquitos por ahí con que se
evapore al ambiente aumentar las la
presión la temperatura y generar las
condiciones para poder tener vida este
sería un muy buen proyecto para poder
colonizar marte
la temperatura de marte de hecho no es
tan diferente a la de la tierra
en un día muy caluroso en marte
tendríamos 30 grados centígrados eso es
bastante cómodo creo que para algunas
personas aquí en la tierra en promedio
tenemos una temperatura bastante fría
que es de menos 60 grados centígrados
aproximadamente si aumentamos la
temperatura de los polos empezaríamos a
generar un proceso conocido como el
proceso de efecto invernadero y de esto
lo conocemos muy muy bien aquí en la
tierra
lamentablemente o afortunadamente
dependiendo de cómo se vea
tenemos alrededor de 100 años
destruyendo el planeta haciendo cosas
aquí
esto es una fortuna para gente como yo
en parte no porque me agrade el imaginar
cómo va a ser el futuro con el planeta
destruido más bien porque tenemos los
elementos de un experimento que ha sido
yo desde mi punto de vista el
experimento más caro en la historia de
la humanidad porque estamos destruyendo
el planeta este experimento nos permite
ver cómo es que contaminando el la
atmósfera de la tierra podemos hacer que
la temperatura aumente dentro de un
periodo de tiempo de alrededor de 100
años hemos visto que la temperatura de
la tierra sin proponérnoslo está
aumentado alrededor de un grado
centígrado aproximadamente las
predicciones que se tienen para el
futuro en la tierra no son muy
alentadoras tenemos que cambiar nuestras
costumbres para poder evitar una
catástrofe sin embargo que estas mismas
predicciones por otro lado nos servirían
para cambiar la atmósfera de marte y eso
es como la ventaja de todo esto que
estamos viendo ahora si utilizamos lo
que estamos viendo aquí
tierra para llevarlo a otros lugares
donde no haya daño a largo plazo podemos
cambiar la superficie de un planeta lo
que para algunas personas solo lo que
para todos nosotros puede ser una cosa
muy muy mala en otro lugar puede ser una
oportunidad y eso es muy interesante si
derretimos los pueblos de marte
podríamos tener más agua en el ambiente
podríamos tener más dióxido de carbono
podríamos aumentar la presión de la
atmósfera si tenemos una atmósfera más
densa podríamos llevar plantas y genes
con ingeniería genética que les permita
sobrevivir a la radiación que llega a la
superficie marciana oa estas bajas
temperaturas estas plantas podrían
empezar a producir oxígeno utilizando el
dióxido de carbono existente en la
atmósfera de marte podriamos después ver
poco a poco es que que la atmósfera de
marte empezaría a cambiar esto tardaría
años muchos muchos años tendríamos
oxígeno que se convertiría después en
ozono gracias a la radiación
la temperatura aumentaría
y empezaríamos a tener agua líquida en
la superficie de marte quizás no sea
este el escenario la ciencia se puede
equivocar quizás alguien dentro de 100
dentro de 10 ó 100 años puede encontrar
un método muchísimo más eficiente para
cambiar la superficie de marte de
momento lo que podemos proponer con la
tecnología y con la ciencia que tenemos
son domos donde podemos sobrevivir los
seres humanos donde podemos sembrar
donde podemos empezar a generar
reacciones químicas para cambiar la
atmósfera marciana dentro de 10 años
vamos a tener cohetes y naves espaciales
probablemente que permitan llevar a los
primeros seres humanos a marte
pero todo esto todas estas visiones del
futuro de ciencia ficción que les estoy
presentando no serían absolutamente
útiles o sea no nos van a servir si
olvidamos que estamos viviendo en el
único planeta que tenemos
carl sagan cuando se dedicaba hacer
divulgación utilizaba un término que me
encanta para describir el planeta tierra
y es el punto azul pálido la tierra es
un lugar maravilloso saber cuáles son
los retos para enfrentarse a un ambiente
tan hostil como es el espacio nos
permite apreciar todas todas las cosas
maravillosas que tenemos aquí en la
tierra el aire que estamos respirando
aquí es una cosa que damos por sentado
el agua que bebemos la tierra para
sembrar todas estas cosas son cosas que
tenemos aquí que tenemos que cuidar y
proteger de esta manera quizás no vamos
a destruir un planeta pero si utilizamos
lo que estamos aprendiendo ahora
mientras lo destruimos podríamos tener
dos planetas para que la humanidad salga
y explore el espacio
quiero que se lleven esto que sepan que
ustedes tienen en sus manos las
propiedades las capacidades para
proteger y cuidar la tierra y si lo
cuidamos a nuestras próximas
generaciones les dejaremos dos planetas
para evitar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]